let's talk about corporate influence in
the media and before I do I am very
aware that we're extremely lucky here on
HBO
we don't have advertisers so if I want
to say that for instance Cadbury cream
eggs are filled with dolphin sperm or or
that old navy clothing makes you look
like a tacky murderer or or that or that
Snickers only satisfies you for about
eight minutes then makes you hate
yourself for the rest of the day I can I
can do all of those things and why well
because of HBO's business model which no
one has been able to adequately explain
to me yet but most other outlets are
locked in a constant battle for
editorial independence with it
which is especially problematic when it
comes to the news America has a proud
tradition of a free and independent
press but it has always been a fight
back in the 50s newscasters like NBC's
John Cameron Swayze were introduced like
this sit back light up a camel and be an
eyewitness to the happenings that made
history in the last 24 hours the camel
news Caravan presents today's news today
produced four Camel cigarettes by NBC
top story this evening Americans life
expectancy is still 45 that's Camel
smooth now exceptions like that aside
it's generally agreed upon in journalism
that there should be a wall separating
the editorial and the business side of
news it's sometimes referred to as the
separation of church and state although
I like to think of news and advertising
is the separation of guacamole and
Twizzlers separately they're good but if
you mix them together somehow you make
both of them really gross but recently
the integrity of news has become harder
to protect particularly in print print
is still where most original journalism
is done but since papers moved online
they have struggled financially mainly
because news is like porn people don't
want to pay for it on the Internet even
though somewhere in a dimly lit room
Paul Krugman worked very hard to make it
online online ah online he worked hard
he put his heart and soul into that
online print publications have struggled
to attract advertisers partly because
traditional banner ads are so
ineffective that one study found
we only intentionally click on them less
than two-tenths of one percent of the
time which actually sounds about right
because did you know that if you ever
actually click on a banner ad you
literally get taken to a page that reads
hey is everything ok I'm presuming you
passed out and hit your head on the
keyboard I'm calling an ambulance right
now
the publishing industry though has
responded to this crisis by finding a
new way to appeal to advertisers native
advertising is basically saying to
corporations that want to advertise we
will camouflage your ads to make them
look like news stories that's
essentially it that's essentially it are
you saying that to sum up your point on
native advertising or are you describing
independent journalism that's
essentially it it's over we're done here
even if you've not heard the term native
advertising before you have probably
been subjected to it by now it's when a
piece of ostensibly normal content is
stamped with tiny disclaimers like this
and this and then contains messages that
are often clear endorsements and if
you'll excuse me I'll just take a break
from making this point by enjoying the
refreshing taste of Mountain Dew Code
Red and then it's at this point that you
usually realize oh this isn't the thing
that I was looking for you're just
advertising the most disgusting drink
ever manufactured although although I
will say it does undeniably taste of red
native advertising though has been so
lucrative for new media organizations
they basically built their entire
business model around it 100% of our
revenue comes from from branded content
so so we have a lot of partners who are
who are marketers and major brands who
work with 76 to the top 100 brands now
that's the CEO of BuzzFeed Jonah Peretti
and his face is like BuzzFeed itself so
successful appealing and yet somehow you
want to punch it BuzzFeed has created
high speed it for high speed has created
masterpieces of native advertising such
as 10 life-changing ways to make your
day more efficient sponsored by GE and
nine ways cleaning has become smarter
sponsored by Swiffer and 11 sea
creatures who deserve to die
sponsored by BP now that that that last
one is a joke but it's not significantly
different from the previous two full
disclosure HBO did pay for lists to
promote this show around the time that
we began very cleverly realizing we
better promote this show no one is going
to give a about it but but the
success of this practice has clearly
impressed old media such as Time Inc
whose CEO recently created a native
advertising team and he also doesn't see
why that might be an issue as long as
it's clearly marked as long as the
consumer knows the difference
in watts editorial and what's native I
don't see any problem with it at all
yep but it is a problem though because
the consumer cannot tell the difference
a recent study showed that less than
half of visitors to a new site could
distinguish native advertising from
actual news and of course they can't
because it's supposed to blend in you're
like a camouflage manufacturer saying
only an idiot could not tell the
difference between that man unfold it I
mean look the camouflage clearly states
not foliage on the collar it's clear and
besides I'm sure the deal knows the
difference between the two things deers
are so smart you have to respect deer
and if you are wondering how he
reconciles this with the line between
church and state well funny story
Craig frankly I've changed Turks and
state as you know we took that away and
we said the editors are going to now be
working for the business side of the
equation but frankly I think they're
happier they're more excited about it
because no longer we asking ourselves
the question are we violating church and
state whatever that was whatever that
was that's like a surgeon saying hey I
found this squishy thing in there all
bloody and gross so I removed it
whatever that was that was the heart
that was what made the whole thing work
you needed that and it's not just Time
Inc that's doing this the Atlantic
published some native advertising for
the Church of Scientology the ad is the
kind you've probably seen it's called
sponsored content it's formatted to look
like an actual article on their website
and the article lavishly praised
Scientology's leader David Miscavige
okay now for the Atlantic that is
ethically compromising but for
Scientology that is just plain stupid
they clearly should have gone with a
magazine with better access to their key
demographic such as depressed aspiring
actor monthly
even even the New York Times is now
embracing this I had a recent feature on
their website about women in prison
which looked like a serious piece of
journalism but was actually a paid post
promoting season two of orange is the
new black and here's the thing as far as
native advertising goes that's about as
good as it gets the reporting is real
and the sponsored branding was minimal
but it is still an ad it's like hearing
the one Katy Perry song that you like
you think sure this is the best possible
iteration of Katy Perry but it still
feels wrong to be listening to this
you're gonna hear me roar louder louder
than a lion it's a good song it's a good
stop there's a 12 year old girl inside
me who is empowered by that song so the
problem is the problem is the problem is
sponsors aren't always going to be as
benign as orange is the new black
sometimes it's going to be a company
like Chevron who recently sponsored a
piece in The Times about how our energy
needs are changing and spoiler alert the
notion that they're changing because
we've got the earth thanks to companies
like Chevron is not the conclusion of
the article you might think all of this
might seriously damage trust in a news
organization but at times advertising
executive would like to vigorously
refute that let me start by vigorously
refuting the notion that native
advertising has to erode consumer trust
or compromise the wall that exists
between editorial and advertising good
native advertising is just not meant to
be trickery it's meant to be publisher
sharing it's it's storytelling tools
with a marketer exactly exactly
it's not trickery it's sharing
storytelling tools and that's not
it's repurposed bovine waste
and look in use a use that is seemingly
the model now ads are baked into content
like chocolate chips into a cookie
except it's actually more like raisins
into a cookie because no one wants them
there and and the point is think how
much it would affect your trust in me as
a source if you knew that that last anti
raisin cookie joke was actually brought
to you by Chips Ahoy but but before we
demonize these organizations for selling
out it is worth remembering this is all
at least partially our fault a press
cannot be free and independent if nobody
is willing to pay for it
and it seems nobody is going to in which
case I'd like to make a suggestion if
our news is going to be corrupted we
should at least get something in return
every time a corporation sneaks
advertising into our news and ruins it
our news should be allowed to sneak into
their advertising
when you get hot you get thirsty and
when you get thirsty there is only one
choice Diet Coke
the recent Ebola outbreaks killed up 700
people in West after the World Health
Organization says they don't yet have it
under control in this situation
threatens to become catastrophic
you